drôle d'ambiance dans l'arrondissement
ouest du département
ici les services de la collectivité sont
en action et ce matin là les centenaires
sont à l'honneur ce sont les cadeaux
pour les centenaires donc comme vous
voyez il ya les enquêtes et des
oreillers à mémoire de forme et une
petite boîte de chocolats franchement
ils sont bien
le territoire compte près de 150
centenaire un chiffre en perpétuelle
augmentation qui donne du sens à
l'action de la collectivité ce que c'est
une de nos missions fondamentales du
département les services actions de
santé et les services alsace occupe au
quotidien et en proximité de nos
personnes âgées à bien elle les visites
pour
leur permettre l'accès à leurs droits
notamment la paix à l'aide ménagère
l'hébergement quand elles font la
demande et leurs familles font la
demande d'hébergement et puis tout là
toute l'instruction administrative de d2
ses demandes
oui
ma fait c'est noël avant avant en état
tous
pendant ce temps marie alexina mada
scène à temps devant sa petite case au
centre de saint paul mais non matin
alexina et où vient d'où nous sommes
sûrs d'aller au mollet nenê au sein si
léo la sardaigne où alassane est né au
mali été déclamés la barre tout ça
ramadan c'est est ce que tu vas bien
tu vois bien là les personnes avait près
de ton âge qui on s'entend centenaire un
petit peu plus haut si tu vois là mais
quand j'arrive la présence compte
beaucoup aussi
voilà le fait que je sois là à côté
d'elle parce qu'il ya aussi pas
seulement le ménage comme on dit ah le
moment de réconfort de parler de tout et
de rien ab polychromie yaoumi amène bien
elle aime bien ça pour tous à cannes il
a tout pour nous nuire au soir simon à
tomber il y avait là elle y arrive
ce n'est pas tous les jours que nous
pouvons rencontrer nos personnes âgées
et vous savez que le département a en
charge justement la politique des
personnes âgées et aussi des personnes
souffrant d'un handicap
c'est essentiel parce qu'on d'abord va
les rencontrer discuter avec nos
personnes âgées mais aussi pour voir
dans quelles conditions elles vivent
on a des travailleurs sociaux qui sont
auprès de ces personnes âgées et bah il
faut aller sur place pour se rendre
compte des conditions dans lesquelles
elles travaillent
et puis des conditions de vie de nos
centenaire près de 150 millions d'euros
sont attribués chaque année à
l'accompagnement de ces personnes en
perte d'autonomie
pourtant marie alexina a toujours été
actif dans sa vie puisqu'elle travaille
on a fait des pieds tandis qu'ici vapeur
pour les apps ou fait travailler un an
jusqu'à dans la grosne du conseil coupe
comme free trou était comme ça mais
quelqu'un comme dedans
c'est formidable
quel plaisir mais il faut qu'on continue
à bientôt
oui mais combien de personnes
aujourd'hui comme cela c'est la
cinquième personne et je crois qu'il y à
13 centres nationaux le territoire de
saint paul nous avons beaucoup à
apprendre et à écouter de nos personnes
âgées de centenaire et contrairement à
ce que l'on pourrait croire
elle se porte plutôt bien croyez moi
parfois mieux que nous mais de ce qui
arrive on est content view a mal
commencé mais pas au final comme ça la
banque se refait confiance
ben c'est à la traite comme ça jusqu'à
tant qu en irrigué ya un pic